fait mais c'est simplement pour se
déguiser en faiseur de fait la ola
saltimbanques
vous êtes là faisant il a pris sa
dernière pilule la pilule on s'en fait
citron il a bu son café j'ai lu et
trouvait que c'était pas bon il s'est
dit mme roy thinnes y en a ras le fera
quand de cet univers qu'ils lisent et
entre 10 et je ne suis pas un numéro je
me donne un nom vous dit pour foutu je
me trouvais dans la gaieté
ah parce que désormais je serai mother
de fait les ordinateurs devient vendée à
cambrai ont gelé les berges entre et des
perdants c'est leur faire la fête
nationale
sortez les violons messieurs dames
écouté ma chanson
oui rivas le retour de l'amour et la
folie mais cela ne cessez de penser ou
ne pensait plus qu'à lancer la vie est
belle paire vivre
mais là
c'est les couleurs mais cela vient
toujours attendre le printemps pour être
fou il s'en fout c'est van zyl
j'essaie de penser ou le pensait plus
qu'à lancer la vie est belle
montalat
hier toujours à temps pour le printemps
pourrait voir les
ils allaient être qu'il en village on
est partout sauver la folie il était
toujours de passage toute la paire
d'enceintes avec lui on le croyait là
étaient déjà partis il se dépense et je
dépasse et brûlé sa vie il a vraiment
dans ce qu il s'est troué raid idée
il n' ont rien fait de fausses oeuvres
de peintres suis avait choisi de rire ou
en pleurer
mais il a laissé de la musique et par la
fait que tous ceux qui l'avaient écouté
et il avait fait ça
cela s'est passé
lucas dans ce pays
et les couleurs vives et les chagrins
des fleurs et le voleur messieurs
l'arbre ya toujours un temps pour le
printemps pour être fou et on s'en fout
cissé
attention messieurs dames pour feu le
faiseur de prête
allons-y
lee
j'essaie de penser ou de poser plus
qu'un danger la vie est belle
bien sûr attendre le printemps pour être
pour cent
c
non